what if the mosasaurus were still alive  this creature went extinct millions of  years ago but if it inhabited our oceans  today that would be very bad news much  of the marine life we know today  probably wouldn't exist that's because  the Mosasaur was an incredibly  aggressive predator and would be able to  eat pretty much anything instead the  fish in the sea would need to adapt  special traits in order to avoid the  Mosasaur but how would this giant lizard  affect you well it would make the oceans  a much more dangerous place for humans  we would need massive boats to be able  to fish and swimming and surfing would  be incredibly dangerous  if the Mosasaur found you it would  definitely have you for dinner without a  second thought so have you ever asked  yourself